something happened while I was studying
in the seminary and training to be a
priest I came in contact with a
different idea of life an idea of life
that contradicted the mintages of
religion humanism some of you may be
wondering what on earth is humanism
humanism is aware of thinking and living
that emphasizes the agency of human
beings humanism stresses the fact that
we human beings are capable of changing
the world that we have their power to
make a difference in our lives but
individually and collectively with our
recourse to some outside force it may
interest you to know that the best
humanist lessons I learned was not from
reading philosophy books or from poring
over
humanist manifestos and declarations no
not at all
the best humanist lesson I learned was
from the life of my own parents my
parents come from a poor family
background in MBC
in southeastern Nigeria they had limited
opportunities but my parents did not
allow the circumstances of their birth
and upbringing to determine the ambition
and dreams for themselves and for their
children my father worked part time
trained as a teacher and rose to become
a headmaster at a local primary school
well my mother dropped out of school
quite early because her mother my
grandmother could not afford our
education as a parent my mother worked
very hard combining farming busy trading
and taking care of my siblings and me by
the time I was born that was shortly
after the Nigerian civil war life was
very difficult a struggle there
my family was living in a heart with the
eye of a child I can see see water
dripping from the touch roof of our
house when it rained my father our goods
to supplement the family income and out
of my duty after school hours or during
vacation was to feed these ghosts there
when they were there was no electricity
no pipe with water we tried to fetch
water from the nearby streams that was
an easy work in the wet season but
kilometres when it was hot and dry to
hard work and perseverance my parents
were able to erect a block apartment and
sent my siblings and me to school they
made it possible for us to enjoy a
standard of living which they never did
and to attend educational levels with
only imagined when they were growing up
my parents life the story is my best
lesson in humanism so as a humanist I
believe that human beings are challenges
not prisoners of faith our destinies are
in our hands not predetermined and
misled for us to ship our lives and
destinies to reflect our best hopes and
aspirations I believe that human beings
have the power to turn situations of
poverty into those of world and
prosperity we have the capacity to
alleviate suffering extend life
prevent diseases here debilitating
ailments reduce infant mortality and
preserve our planet but we cannot
accomplish all these goals by wishful
thinking with our eyes closed or by
unjust speculation or by expecting
salvation from empty sky in contrast
millions of Africans imagine that their
religious faith will have that dream
come true and they spend so much time
praying for miracles and for divine
intervention in their lives in 2009 a
Gallup survey in 114 countries revealed
that religiosity was highest in the
world's poorest nations
in fact six of the 10 countries where
95% of their population said that
religion was an important part of their
daily lives we are African in some cases
religion drives many Africans to
extraordinary lengths to attack other
human beings to commit ritual killing
targeting those living with albinism
those which hunchback and as i recently
learned those with bad head in Africa
superstition is widespread with so many
people believe in witchcraft something
that has no basis in risen oil science
yet alleged witches usually women
children and elderly peasants are still
routinely attacked banished and killed
and have made it but of my life's
mission to end witchcraft accusation
which persecution in Africa so as a
humanist I believe in a proactive
approach to life the changes that we
want cannot be achieved only by dreaming
were required in as well the challenges
that we face cannot go away if we recall
our retreat into ourselves wishing and
imagining that those problems will
somehow magically disappear the good
life that we desire will not fall like
manna from heaven
my parents did not erect a block
apartment by wishing and dreaming they
worked hard they felt the train again
they toured with rolled-up sleeves with
the hands deep in debt they plowed ahead
growing their dreams into reality so as
a humanist I believe we must be
adventurous and even daring the part of
success is paved with risk and
uncertainties we have to muster the will
and courage to do what people have never
done to think what people have never
thought envisage what people have never
imagined go to places human beings have
not been to and succeed where people
have tried but failed we must be ready
to explore new frontiers of knowledge
and understanding and attempt to do it
not just what is possible but also what
is seemingly impossible but
I realize that at end of the day our
efforts do not always yield our desires
we fail we suffer disappointments and
setbacks some problems such as Wars our
conflict poverty and diseases and all
that natural and human-made disasters
seem as if they may never go away
solutions to old problems have led to
new dangerous new cures to diseases have
resulted in new health risk but the fact
that this problems persists and that
solution sometimes cleared their own
problems is not a reason for us to give
up or to resign it's not a reason for us
to think that our efforts have no
consequence in fact yes fulfilment is
driving and trying to provide answers
and solutions to the problem humanity
faces even the likely outcome is felling
up
so as a humanist I believe we must not
despair for Humanity even in the face of
overwhelming difficulties and in the
bleeker's of circumstances
human beings are creative beings we have
the power to generate new ideas new
solutions and new ideas new ideas new
solutions and new cures so my despair
when the unexpected knocks on the
horizon it is in our nature to create
anew to be inventive and innovative so
while languish in idle expectation of a
savior from above so it is time for us
Africans to take our destiny in our
hands and realize we have agency in the
scheme of life we need to put an end to
this game of blend that has prevented us
from taking full responsibility for our
lives for too long we have been
prisoners of our past we have allowed
despair and pessimism to drain us drain
our energies limit our imaginations and
dim our vision for a better and brighter
future we have left this continent
wonder why passing the ball like a
frisbee
with bland slavery colonialism and the
new colonialism for the wars we
experienced including our own
self-inflicted wounds we have conducted
ourselves in ways that seemed as if
Africa is done and owned and that all
these experiences in history have
reversibly irreparably foreclosed the
chances and possibility for Africa to
image tribe and flourish we must realize
that there is no part of the world that
has not been colonized or enslaved in
the past and if other parts of the world
have moved on why can't we now so as a
humanist I believe that the past is gone
we cannot change it we cannot alter it
but the future beckons us on with
limitless possibilities to recreate
reshape remake our destinies so let let
all of us seize this opportunity and as
my parents did begin the audience task
of rebuilding Africa brick by brick
let's give free rein to our ideas our
imaginations as demonstrated at this Ted
global 2017 let's open our hearts and
mind and and exert our energy
intelligence and ingenuity and begin the
audience task of rebuilding Africa and
of transforming this continent into a
citadel of our rival prosperity and
civilization this is what I believe as a
humanist as an African humanist thank
you
[Applause]